c'est le moment de notre panel politique
avec hélène buzzetti qu'avec michel
serrault g et on ne joue pas avec nous
ce soir frédéric boily politologue qui
basé à l'université de l'alberta
edmonton bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir
d'abord ce point de presse en juste
avant qu'on entre en ondes à 17h justin
trudeau qui a décidé de lever
l'application de cette loi sur les
mesures d'urgence écouter la loi elle a
été sanctionnée en fait voter adopté par
la chambre lundi le transit au tour du
sénat dette entraînent débattre là
dessus voici pourquoi il décide de la
retirer on écoute
aujourd'hui après avoir soigneusement
examiné la situation on constate qu'on
est plus en situation d'urgence c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement fédéral met fin
à la loi sur les mesures d'urgence on
juge maintenant que les lois en place
sont suffisantes pour assurer la
sécurité de la population
évidemment on va continuer de soutenir
les autorités locales et provinciales au
besoin
alors hélène c'était absolument
incontournable on avait besoin cette
loi-là l'indicé à justin trudeau on est
deux jours plus tard et on en a plus
besoin qu'est ce que s'est passé
et moi j'entends dans les propos de
monsieur trudeau un désaveu très solide
envers la police d'ottawa parce que
quand on écoute bien tout ce qui le dit
incluant la citation vous venez de faire
jouer il dit on a les lois actuelles et
loire régulière sont suffisantes pour
empêcher le retour de ceux qui se
retrouvent comme ça en ce moment en
banlieue d'ottawa donc on les lois sont
suffisantes pour rempla empêcher
l'implantation des manifestants mais une
fois qu'ils étaient implantés là ça nous
prenait des outils supplémentaires pour
les déloger de là lorsque j'en comprends
moi c'est que rodez on désavoue la
police d'ottawa qui n'a pas fait ce
qu'il fallait pour empêcher cette
implantation des gens et il ya peut-être
aussi quoique c'est spéculatifs qu'on a
voulu éviter le vote au sénat qui selon
toute évidence aurait eu lieu demain les
sénateurs étant ce qu'ils sont il n'y a
pas vraiment de ligne de parti votre
commune veut et on pense que ça aurait
peut-être pas passer ça répète un vote
de confiance comme à la chambre commune
donc possible que ça ne passe pas
s'arrêter une forme de deux camouflets
pour monsieur trudeau et peut-être
continue éviter cette situation
embarrassante
est ce que c'est ce que vous pensez
aussi michel janva en finale
il ya des sénateurs des jurys
écouter non ce qui s'est passé là est
contraire à la charte c'était pas
c'était pas le tas de d'utiliser la loi
des mesures d'urgence aussi
s'il y avait des gros chance qu'on sait
n'est pas grave ça
mise en danger mais ça aurait eu l'air
très foot on a préféré avoir l'air fou
d'une autre façon c'est à dire de dire à
72 heures tout s'est calmé tout à fait
c'est merveilleux
je pense que ça prouve
ce qu'ils aiment cette indolence et on
en a maintenant tous les outils pour
éviter d'autres blocages monsieur boily
son garde dans les faits il ya encore
une manifestation à winnipeg là ils ont
un ultimatum là ils étaient partis sont
venus les camionneurs il ya aussi on va
montrer une carte en banlieue d'ottawa
il ya encore des camionneurs que cube
certains endroits des terrains privés et
qui ont l'air d'attendre de nouvelles
mobilisations je sais pas trop quoi pour
peut-être revenir à ottawa peut-être pas
on peut peut-être l'a montré la carte
vous voyez sur les 33 luxe sont en rouge
ici et il ya aussi cette menace de
bloquer un pont qui est crucial pour
l'île-du-prince-édouard le pont de la
confédération c'est une manifestation
qui sont est en train s'organiser dans
ce secteur là donc ça veut dire que le
mouvement là le mouvement de
manifestations il ne s'est pas était
monsieur boily mais on pense qu'on est
complètement capable de se passer de
cette loi tu seras les mesures oui bien
monsieur trop double dit aussi la menace
est encore l'homme mais maintenant on a
les outils nécessaires avec les lois
actuelles pour être capable de faire
face à ces manifestations lui en a eu
aussi encore cette fin de semaine à
edmonton du côté de la saskatchewan
également
peut-être aussi que du côté des
manifestants on peut être voir également
la façon dont on manifeste pour éviter
justement d'avoir l'air de vouloir
établir une occupation bloquer des ponts
et donc que les manifestations également
vont tenir uni manifestants vont tenir
compte de tout ça et j'ajouterai une
chose aussi dans le spéculatif qui était
évoquée par hélène buzzetti j'ai
l'impression qu'il va peut-être
également sur le moyen terme entre corte
des considérations partisanes la part de
monsieur tourdot c'est à dire que on a
vu que la loin sur les mesures d'urgence
permettait de donner un certain simon
aucun conservateur et le je parle de la
famille conservatrice au sens large dans
le vus ici en alberta jason kenny qui a
sauté très rapidement sur la
dénonciation de la loi et je pense que
du côté des libéraux on commence à
s'apercevoir que il y avait cet effet
l'eau est prévu que ça donne une sorte
de momentum montre un nouveau souffle
certains conservateurs et que c'était
peut-être le temps de reculer parce que
les conséquences imprévues de toujours
pouvait devenir difficile à gérer pour
le camp libéral j'aimerais qu'on parle
maintenant de la façon dont ces manifs
et sont les gens qui sont liés ce grand
mouvement de manifestations la façon
dont ils appréhendent la politique
canadienne la comprennent en discutent
entre eux parce qu'on a l'impression à
lire à gauche et à droite qu'on nage en
pleine confusion un point tel que du
bureau de la gouverneure générale on a
dû y mettre un message d'un bureau n'a
eu saimone pour dire écoutez on dément
toute rumeur le prétendant que moi je
comme le gouverneur général je peux
retirer la confiance à l'endroit du
gouvernement trudeau les manifestants
parlait d'un espèce de mouvement de vote
de non-confiance visait de renvoyer une
sorte de pétition signée son nom l
écoute est absolument poids exact c'est
un exemple parmi d'autres hélène ils ont
l'air confus aussi avec les lois
américaines
on parle du conjoint lors d'une d'un des
leaders du mouvement de camionneurs le
convoi de l2 sous ce doux qu'on doit la
madame leila qui a plaidé le premier
amendement lors de son audience pour sa
liberté sous caution on n'a pas sûr au
canada même là je n'en revenais pas de
quoi vous parlez est exactement ça se
trouve aux états unis c'est ce qu'évoque
monsieur tron comment vous la comprenez
cette confusion pourquoi il ya autant de
confusion mais écoutez d'abord c'est
s'est généralisé dans la population de
mal comprendre des institutions
politiques ne ce n'est pas propre à la
droite ou aux camionneurs et c'est sûr
que c'est tentant en regardant ça de
dire que voilà l'effet discours tromper
ce qui
perd coller dans l'esprit de ces gens
mais moi je vois plus largement je pense
que c'est généralement au canada il ya
beaucoup d' influence américaine et
particulièrement auprès des canadiens
anglais anglophones qui contrairement au
québécois francophones par exemple donc
pas cette barrière de la langue ils
baignent dans cette culture américaine
ils regardent la télé ils baignent dans
leur imaginaire américain et donc il
n'en arrive à plus tout à fait faire la
distinction entre les deux réalités mais
moi je vous dirais qu'il faut faire
attention ce n'est pas propre à la
droite que de faire ça oui d'accord le
tropisme on a vu par exemple des gens
qui scandait la cup en parle
aux etats unis mais ce n'est pas propre
à la droite regardez la gauche aussi la
gauche qui est porte ici au canada une
lecture par exemple raciale de toutes
les tensions sociales dans la société
alors que les tensions raciales au
canada n'ont absolument rien à voir avec
celle des états unis cette idéologie par
le passé moi l'expression web aussi qui
nous vient beaucoup des états unis alors
c'est je pense autant à gauche qu'à
droite
il ya une espèce de damages gamme qui
est fait avec les états unis on importe
toutes sortes de concept américain qui
ne colle pas nécessairement à la réalité
canadienne de bouali est ce que c'est
encore plus fort ce que helen kane
d'écrire dans l'ouest canadien est ce qu
on est comme une sorte de glissement de
perte d'identité canadien on voit
davantage comme des américains
bon d'abord l'influencé américaine du
côté notamment de l'alberta les l'autre
depuis les débuts même de l'alberta en
tant que province donc ça ce n'est pas
nécessairement nouveau il faut se
rappeler d'ailleurs quand stephen harper
arrive on arrive au pouvoir on
l'accusait de néoconservatisme ce qui
était pas un compliment parce qu'on
disait qu'il était comme georges de
bellio boucher s'est fait qu'on
néoconservateurs qui voulaient aller
faire la guerre au moyen-orient donc
sauce est déjà présent ce qui nous vous
jure aujourd'hui c'est quand même une
certaine radicalisation dans cette
influence l'autre à droite c'est à dire
qu'elle est présente et il peut y avoir
une influence tout à fait à dison
normale entre la droite américaine de la
droite canadienne le passage d'idées de
la frontière qui peut être normal mais
aujourd'hui c'est une question aussi
d'une certaine radicalisation et de
confusion du discours qui était
probablement paulo auparavant et qui est
engendrée notamment par l'effet aussi
des médias sociaux et la rapidité aussi
avec laquelle selon sa fin et il faut
pas oublier où c'est le rôle des médias
traditionnels je pense notamment fox
news qui a donné beaucoup de temps
d'antenne à toutes les manifestations
donc cette combinaison l'a fait en sorte
qu'on se retrouve dans un étang à la
fois de radicalisation sur les franges
de la droite et de confusion idéologique
qui lui qui elle s'est un peu plus mais
vous vous êtes basé en alberta ce que
c'est vous ce que vous constatez autour
de vous ça vient des albertains qui
compte holmes fonctions ce
principalement comme source
d'information n'ont pas nécessairement
juste fonctions aux usa c'est une
influence que on sent par différents
canaux et aussi une influence qui peut
se manifester en raison d'une proximité
qui est à la fois géographique mais
aussi qui est économique c'est à dire
que on a les mêmes préoccupations dans
l'ouest souvent qu'on retrouve dans
l'ouest américain par exemple l'histoire
des convois de camions mois les premiers
convois que j'ai vu bon il ya eu celui
en 2019 ici en alberta qui était
descendue vers ottawa mais on a eu
également du côté de l'orégon qui était
dans sa nature même exactement pareil
2010 et 2019 et 2020 également des
convois de camions la capitale de l'état
de rayon à salem où on allait contester
les mesures en matière de lutte aux
changements climatiques
et ça revenait aussi dans l'ouest donc
il ya ce passage non en raison d'une
proximité géographique et michel comment
ça on est pas tout ça sur la politique
canadienne sur les partis politiques au
canada
d'abord l'influencé américaine et l'on
peut pas la nier déjà aux états unis
alors ça fait quelque chose c'est pas
juste le premier amendement 7/5 aussi
mais il reste on a vu dans les
manifestations de perroy et ailleurs
aussi des drapeaux
de la campagne trempe ses semis pour
rien j'ai cherché toute la journée les
codes des côtes de fox news au canada
avec le chiffre n'existe pas mais c'est
clair que déjà comme tant que console
qui va dès l'été chute des camionneurs
d'ailleurs quand même pas mal et
jeunesse qui va était celle des
camionneurs mais ça reviendra pas
là-dessus
et c'est sûr que ça a une influence au
canada c'est sur une frange radicale sûr
c'est très clair mais cette frange leur
avait dit qu'elle s'est manifestée
à ottawa au cours de la manifestation
des trois semaines c'est tout le monde
de ceux de cette manifestation aulaqi et
dans une frange radicale mais les
leaders en était
et il ya donc venant des états unis mais
aussi le nom de quelque chose d'un terne
au canada une radicalisation de la
droite un refuge à la faveur des mesures
senneterre on n'est pas le seul pays où
sensible mais alors justement ce
portrait qu'on vient de brosser de cette
influence américaine je vous pose la
question si un élève comment vous la
voyez se traduire quel impact sur nos
partis politiques parce qu'une tentation
d'aller chercher ces gens là d'aller
prendre cette colère le il a tourné à
son avantage qu'on est un parti et il y
a une espèce de
situations qui râlent à droite plus à la
mode monsieur voilier en parlais tout à
l'heure on le voit et ce n'est pas que
propre au parti conservateur mais on
voit par exemple éric duhaime au québec
qui se hisse en seconde place chez les
francophones le parti conservateur qui
reprend les devants selon un dernier
sondage bien confortablement devant les
libéraux on verra si c'est ça dure mais
il ya une espèce de conjectures qui fait
que les gens en ce moment il ya une
fatigue pandémique très évidente donc se
traduit pour plusieurs par une colère et
donc tout d'un coup ils sentent que le
parti sont les partis conservateurs au
sens large sont mieux à même de porter
ce message est donc on le voit que ça
vient gonfler leur intention de voter je
pense monsieur boyer avait raison de
dire que peut-être que monsieur trudeau
au fait cette lecture et c'est ce qui
l'amène à tout de suite se rétracter
ceci dit monsieur duhaime à québec voit
beaucoup plus rapidement aller aux urnes
et pourra peut-être encaissé là dessus
alors que les conservateurs à ottawa
enfin dieu nous en garde on n'a pas une
élection pour pour demain matin et donc
peut-être que font un mauvais calcul
stratégique de tout miser là dessus sur
cette colère les camionneurs ecce terra
peut-être que dans deux ans il n'en
restera plus grand chose et tout ce
qu'on ressouvenir c'est que le grand
parti de la loi et l'ordre n'a pas voulu
rétablir l'ordre à ottawa une dernière
dernière question en moins d'une minute
michel on vous avez beaucoup parlé d'un
jean charest qui pourrait éventuellement
se porter comme candidat mais semble que
monsieur rappaz sera encore prêt lui
bloqué la route cette fois ci
écoutez monsieur harper est encore très
influent dans le parti conservateur il
ya pas besoin d'eux
bloquer la route physiquement il peut
faire juste trois quatre téléphones
discret mais il est clair que c'est pas
le même genre de conservateurs c'est
clair que depuis
2007 le règlement du déséquilibre fiscal
que monsieur changer
cette histoire là y'a pas d'atomes
crochus entre ces deux hommes là il ya
déjà mais sait déjà qu'ils appuyaient
jean charest qui m'aimait et puis
données nationales et autre chose
si je joue j'ai hâte de voir parce qu'il
est quand même capable de faire savoir
ce qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils n'aiment
pas de façon discrète mais très efficace
et bien voilà c'est tout le temps on
avait aimé ça disent qu elle est
tellement passionnante justement sur
l'influencé américaine sur nos
manifestants mais aussi sur les
politiciens sur nous tous en réalité on
veut souvent avoir l'occasion de la
poursuivre merci d'avoir été avec moi ce
soir au plaisir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit